au programme de la journée pour cette
famille lyonnaise
une balade en calèche avec arrêt au
belvédère des gorges du doubs suivie
d'un repas au restaurant
un programme qui fait habituellement le
plein en période estivale mais qui cette
année a été boudée en juillet depuis
quelques années le mois de juillet ne se
confirme pas heureusement qu'il ya un
retour sur route ou là effectivement
depuis une dizaine de jours on a du
monde mais il faut attendre aujourd'hui
plus tôt le 10 août pour voir vraiment
bougé sur le site du saut du loup même
tendance ici dans cette structure de 70
chambres et restaurants l'établissement
affiche même un taux d'occupation en
hausse de 20% en août par rapport à l'an
dernier mais avec des touristes qui ne
réservent plus à l'avant ce qu'on sent
que les gens sont indécises attendent la
petite promo qui valait décidé en plus
la météo était favorable donc voilà ça
nous a permis de bien travailler souvent
après le 15 août c'est beaucoup plus
calme alors que nous là cette semaine
qui se termine on avait quand même 80
personnes dans la maison et que des
familles donc c'est quand même
intéressant les offices du tourisme du
secteur annonce peut avoir accueilli
plus de monde que l'an dernier mais sur
des séjours souvent cours c'est là où
c'est très important que depuis quelques
années il ya une vraie volonté politique
pour développer le tourisme en pays
horloger et que le réseau s'anime pour
que chaque acteur du tourisme en pays
horloger prenne bien conscience qu'il
est l'ambassadeur de son territoire et
qu'il a tous les atouts pour faire
rester les touristes en pays horloger
paysage produits du terroir artisanat la
région a de quoi convaincre
reste à le faire savoir